oh this is cellphone man on this trusty
pouch here mate we're not here to take
your call right now but if you leave
your name and number after the beep
why what is that busy signal monster
call only verification what you mean
first I will destroy the city then the
world
lord he's using his laser eyes to wipe
out the top we have our work cut out for
us ring tone and you come at them from
the front I'll take it from the side
right
southern man do you remember the super
hyper deflect your energy beam but that
was only the beginning stages we have no
idea if it'll work it's the only thing
that could possibly just let the power
of his death fire but even if it did the
blast firm it is just too darn strong
you you'll never survive as if people
are already dying here it's madness rate
own madness if it means saving the lives
is my check when you do this right oh
nine I love you I know my dear cellphone
that is a single monster your history
that's what you are
and now finishing one you shall stop me
I cannot very tough right justice
congratulations alpha man you defeated
the monster once again as bear I'll see
you get the key to the city for this yes
but will they bring back to let me check
out the back
now what was it all for what was the
purpose of such senseless destruction I
don't know I'm gonna kind of women
somewhere now guitar death is but a
window a closed for window
do not read my tears or instantly
raped oh I miss you so much
- this should pass your future surprise
what the flick wonder possibility beyond
your wildest dreams my life is great oh
my I love you anything in the world I
can do for you anything at all yes
anything
I will return
I will
that was a beautiful story an
action-adventure was truly wonderful um
this is your boss I was gonna fire you
for not showing up to work for several
weeks but gosh darn it I'm just so moved
you can keep your job as long as you
want I don't care um I'm gonna call back
one more time so I can hear that
incredible story again please don't pick
up oh oh this is cell phone man I miss
trusty person ear rape - we're not here
to take your call right now
my mom went the same way